[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir schreiben den sommer 2022 und der
von uns bereits anfang februar
vorhergesagt der langjährige
zermürbungskrieg zwischen russland und
der ukraine ist bittere realität
geworden trotz gravierender operativer
so ein strategischer fehler bei denen
man sich noch ungläubig die augen reiben
konnte ist es den russen in den ersten
wochen gelungen rund 20 prozent des
ukrainischen territoriums zu erobern und
den großen teilen auch zu halten ende
anschließenden nun bereits über
zweieinhalb monate dauernden schlacht um
den dom bass kam sie doch nur sehr
schleppend voran und jeder meter
vormarsch kam die russische armee teuer
zu stehen zumal dieser nur dank ihrer
damals noch vorhandenen artillerie
überlegenheit möglich war und damit
diese irgendwann nicht mehr gegeben ist
ist die unterstützung der ukraine durch
den westen so wichtig dass
opportunitätskosten zu erfolgreichen
anwendungen ihrer brut force taktik
schließt sich mit jeder neuen
waffenlieferung der nato-staaten an
kehrt vor allem jene artillerie systeme
die den russischen überlegen sind putin
weiß das nur zu gut musste seinen
truppen aber dennoch eine erholungspause
gönnen da die vorbereitung der
ukrainischen gegen offensive im süden
des landes zurück oberen der besetzten
gebiete preis auf hochtouren laufen
moskau arbeitet derweil an konzept einer
verdeckten mobilmachung den
verzweifelten versuchen mehr soldaten in
den krieg zu bekommen ohne diese
unpopuläre tatsache offen zugeben zu
müssen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der harten realität eines
zermürbungskrieg es nach 8 von des
ersten weltkriegs in kommen eben weder
ein putin noch die ukraine denn
natürlich ist die brutale schlacht um
den don was auch für die ukraine
zermürbend sie verlost die soldaten und
ihre infrastruktur wird durch das
russische model weiterhin zerstört nun
kommt es also darauf an wer den längeren
atem hat wer länger durchhält der
langfristig die meisten menschlichen und
technischen ressourcen mobilisieren kann
und genau zu diesem zweck hat gehe es
neben der rüstungs hilfe aus dem westen
noch ein weiteres ass im ärmel mit den
bei uns in diesem video beschäftigen
wollen dieses es ist eine neue art volle
reserve streitkräften der informierung
die ukraine kräftig vorangetrieben hat
und weiter vorantreibt am ersten tag der
invasion wandte sich präsident selensky
mit folgenden worten an sein volk
[Musik]
durch
wir alle werden noch gut die bilder im
kopf haben wie viele mutige ukraine
diesen aufruf folgen sicht halten den
einfachsten mitteln auf die verteidigung
ihrer heimat vorbereiteten organisiert
wurde sie dabei vor allem in der so
genannten territorialverteidigung welche
seit kriegsausbruch eine nicht
unerhebliche rolle gespielt hat dennoch
hört man seither nicht mehr viel von ihr
und das wollen wir in diesem video
ändern worum geht es also bei der
ukrainischen territorialverteidigung
warum ist ihre bedeutung so groß wann
ist die ihr standen und wie ist die
organisiert wie arbeitet diese
teilstrecke macht und vor allem welche
rolle spielt sind aktuellen krieg doch
eins nach dem anderen vor einiger zeit
haben wir euch ein video versprochen
indem wir die ukrainische seite und ihre
bedeutung für den weiteren kriegsverlauf
analysieren werden während wir jedoch
fleißig an diesem thema geschrieben
haben hat es sich quasi unter unserer
fehler suchen weit aufgefächert dass wir
zum schluss gekommen sind dass wir es
auch mehrere videos aufteilen müssen
heute kommt also der erste streich und
glaubt mir die weiteren folgen sogleich
also aber unglücklich nicht vergessen
falls sie nicht schon aktiviert sind ich
danke euch so und jetzt lasst uns doch
die immer mit einem kurzen blick in die
geschichte beginnen
[Musik]
eine lektion auf die harte tour
der zerfall der sowjetunion führte zu
großer verwirrung und unsicherheit die
lage war heikel besonders weil die
sowjetische nuklear waffen nicht nur in
der russischen teilrepublik stationiert
waren denn es waren noch auf dem
territorium dreier weiterer street
republiken atomwaffen verbieten ene
weißrussland in kasachstan und in der
ukraine
nach dem fall dass somit union stand der
neuen regierung so mit einem mal das
drittgrößte atomwaffenarsenal der welt
zur verfügung doch es waren den 90er
jahre der kalte krieg war gerade zu ende
gegangen und frieden stimmung machte
sich breit unter diesem eindruck
unterzeichneten die vereinigten staaten
das vereinigte königreich russland und
die drei ehemaligen sowjet-republiken
1994 das sogenannte budapest anne [ __ ]
an die darin vereinbarten sie dass
weißrussland kasachstan und die ukraine
ihre atomwaffen an russland abgeben
würden im gegenzug erhielten sie
sicherheitsgarantien der usa
großbritanniens und ironischerweise auch
von russland das heißt auch die garantie
der territorialen integrität natürlich
lieferten diese garantie nicht eben ein
anreiz für die ukraine in ihrer
verteidigung zu investieren und ihre
armee zu modernisieren
[Musik]
was man an materialen und organisation
vorzuweisen hat bestimmte und stand zum
teil noch aus der sowjetzeit dazu zählt
sie zum beispiel lange liegen der
pflicht diese war unter den store jetzt
noch drei jahre lang später dann nur
noch 12 bis 18 monate und wurde 2013
vollständig abgeschafft das hielt jedoch
nicht lange denn wir alle wissen über
viel russland schon im darauffolgenden
jahr die ukraine also führte man die
wehrpflicht wieder ein und das obwohl
aus sicht von militärexperten schon
damals klar war dass sie im rahmen der
kriegsführung ein erster optimales
konzept darstellt und die modernisierung
des militärs gab behindern kann aber zu
diesem zeitpunkt hatte sich das
ukrainische volk bereits zweimal gegen
putins marionette präsident viktor
janukowitsch erhoben das erste mal in
der orangenen revolution weil er die
wahl manipuliert hatte und ein zweites
mal beim euro meiden weil ein
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu nicht
unterzeichnen wollte und mit den
russischen überfall 2014 erfuhren die
ukraine dann endgültig dass es schutz
vor gewaltbereiten potentaten wie putin
nicht umsonst gibt zugleich stießen sie
jedoch auf eine sehr schmerzhafte
realität bei sich selbst jahrelang
korruption und aufgrund der leeren
garantie versprechungen vernachlässigte
investitionen sollten dafür dass der
ukraine damals nur etwa 6000
kampfbereite soldaten sowohl standen die
zugleich unter mangelhafter
kommunikation ausrüstung aufklärung und
führung klicken kurzum ein desaster und
genau dieses desaster versuchte die
ukraine unter poroschenko und seelands
gegen den letzten jahren zu beheben wie
es nur ging
wie ihr seht hat die ukraine seit der
invasion 2014 viel in die modernisierung
ihres militärs investiert es scheint
ihnen klar geworden zu sein dass das
budapest an umrandung kaum das papier
wert war auf dem es stand im jahr 2010
lag das problem der ukraine auf der hand
die reguläre armee war unzureichend
versorgt und organisiert sie verfügte
gerade einmal über ein budget das kommt
zwei prozent des bip eines der ärmsten
länder europas ausmachte dh im jahr 2014
betrugen die militärausgaben des landes
kaum mehr als 2,5 milliarden dollar das
ist eindeutig zu wenig um eines der
flächenmäßig größten ländern europas
verteidigen zu können noch zumal gegen
eine militärische großmacht russland
neben der budgeterhöhung ergriff man
noch zahlreiche weitere maßnahmen um die
ukrainische der fähigkeit zu verbessern
[Musik]
man ordnet etwa die führungsstruktur neu
führte neue strategien nach nato vorbild
ein und gründete nicht zuletzt
freiwillige kampfverbände um die
mannstärke der ukrainischen armee weiter
zu erhöhen die aus unseren früheren
video wird ist der militärische konflikt
seit 2014 zwischen russland und der
ukraine nie ganz abgerissen die kämpfe
hielten die ganze zeit an der grenze zu
dem selbst ernannten sogenannten
volksrepublik und tony scott lohans nur
weiter
im grunde genommen dauert die schlacht
um den dollars nicht wie eingangs
erwähnt erst zweieinhalb monate sondern
acht jahre und hat vor ihr nun wirklich
heißen phase bereits 14.000
menschenleben gefordert und um diesen
schon jahrelang zermürbenden kampf
durchzuhalten setzte die ukraine
besonders auf jene freiwilligen hat
zivilen halb militärischen verbände die
vergangenen jahre waren wir es die zeit
der sogenannten territorialverteidigung
bataillone man wollte dass diese truppen
zum einen in der lage waren guerillas in
russischen rückraum zu organisieren vom
sog aus und verunsicherung zu stiften
auf der anderen seite sollten sie auf
dem eigenen territorium der reguläre
armee ergänzen da sich diese verbände
als einigermaßen effektiv erwiesen haben
machte man sich in kiew bald daran die
territorialverteidigung bataillone gehen
die reguläre militärstruktur zu
integrieren jahrelang wurde debattiert
was ihre genauen kompetenz und aufgaben
sein würden es sollten hilfstruppen sein
die in keiner direkten konkurrenz zur
eigentlichen armee steht allerdings
gestaltete es sich schwierig diese
position klar zu definieren am ende
zogen sich die diskussion so lange hin
dass das entsprechende gesetz zu
nationalen widerstand erst am ersten
januar diesen jahres in kraft trat damit
führte man die einzelnen bataillone in
einer neuen teilstreitkraft mit
einheitliche organisationsstruktur
zusammen mit der territorialverteidigung
der ukraine gerade einmal knapp 50 tage
vor beginn der russischen invasion
zunächst wurde festgelegt dass um einen
kern von 10.000 erfahrenen soldaten
130.000 reservisten in 35 brigade
formiert werden sollten als sich die
russischen übungs manöver an der grenze
passierten sollten diese dann auf 1,5
bis 2 millionen reservisten und
freiwillige aufgestockt werden
während russland also allmählich seine
streitkräfte an der ukrainischen grenze
zusammenzogen dementiert das signal aus
dass man vorbereitet war dass sich die
dinge geändert hatten und dass man
dieses mal nicht ein so leichtes opfer
wie 2014 sein würde der bedarf der
territorialverteidigung an schusswaffen
und munition ist glaubt juli hanno stein
kommandeur der territorialverteidigung
vollständig gedeckt im kriegsfall sollte
die territorialverteidigung als ein atom
motivationshilfe dienen zur kontrolle
besetzten gebiet ist zur logistischen
unterstützung aufklärung und auch für
partizan und theorie aktionen die idee
war die verteidigung dadurch dichter und
flexibler zu machen und es den angreifer
damit zu schweren ukrainisches gebiet zu
kontrollieren
man kann sich also mit der alten
preußischen landtag vergleichen und
innerhalb der bundeswehr kommt ihr
vielleicht der heimat schuss am nächsten
apropos preußen ab 2016 fand aufbau der
ukrainischen territorialverteidigung
übrigens hand in hand mit der
aufstellung der polnischen armee zur
territorialverteidigung stadt denn beide
länder hatten die russland als
gemeinsame feind ausgemacht und
schlossen sich daher gegen ihn zusammen
holt die albis hat dieser feind dann
seine drohungen schließlich wahr gemacht
und die ukraine direkt ohne weiteres
proxy täter überfallen die frage lautet
also was hat die territorialverteidigung
seither der ukraine tatsächlich gebracht
welche rolle spielt sie im derzeitigen
krieg
[Musik]
die große mobilmachung
am 24 februar 2022 begann die invasion
der erste russische vorstoß war
verheerend für beide seiten vorne
weißrussland aus versuchten die
russischen truppen kiew einzukesseln im
osten erreichten sie die vororte von
charakteren drückten aus doch jetzt und
lugansk vor und nach ihre die russische
armee von der krim aus ein und nahmen
milito pro person ein bevor sie mit der
brutalen belagerung von mario pohl
begann und an diesem punkt muss die
ukraine in den besetzten gebieten das
zuvor gelernte in die praxis umsetzt
unsere leute tun alles um
sicherzustellen dass das land unter den
füßen der besatzer brennt die war petrov
bürgermeister von metropol seit beginn
der invasion haben sich viele unter
ihnen der territorialverteidigung
angeschlossen offiziellen zahlen zufolge
waren es im märz bereits etwa 100.000
das ist eine durchaus beachtliche zahl
denn laut vieler experten ist auf
russischer seite die bereitschaft der
russischen bevölkerung sich freiwillig
zum kriegsdienst zu melden weitaus
geringer zumindest werden die
rekrutierungsbüros dort nicht gerade
überrannt ein faktor der gerade dann
langwierigen konflikt klickst
entscheidend sein kann
wie gesagt müssen jedoch auch zwischen
zwei sehr unterschiedlichen typen von
soldaten in diesen streitkräften
unterscheiden auf der einen seite haben
wir die freiwilligen wie vor der
invasion nur wenige wochen ausbildung
genossen haben entsprechend wenig
militärisches wissen mitbringen und auf
der anderen die berufssoldaten und
sonstige profis in der sicherheit fest
die als offiziere in den verbänden
fungieren viele veteranen des donners
krieges haben sich für diese
streitkräfte entschieden und bilden nun
die neuen freiwilligen aus und führen
sie an das problem ist inzwischen
allerdings dass viele der erfahrungen
soldaten sich entschieden haben die bei
direkt an die front zu gehen dort werden
sie besser bezahlt und können einen
größeren beitrag zur landesverteidigung
leisten wenn noch der beitrag der
territorialen streitkräfte ist nach wie
vor sehr wichtig ihr großer vorteil ist
ihre ortskerne lässt so können sie
leichter strategisch wichtige orte
identifizieren hinter hatte organisieren
und russische investoren schneller
entdecken
[Musik]
das liegt besonders auch in den
freiwilligen die sich spontan der
territorialverteidigung angeschlossen
haben die meisten festnahmen von
sabotage gruppen die für den kreml in
der ukraine agieren sind bienen zu
verdanken und natürlich ist die
territorialverteidigung auch bewaffnet
waffen für alle in der ganzen ukraine
bilden sich milizen leeren sich die
russischen streitkräfte nähern lieber
visual politik zuschauer das
grundlegende ziel der
territorialverteidigung ist es basale
aufgaben fernab der front zu erfüllen
die aber einen hohen personalaufwand
erfordern es geht zum beispiel um die
einrichtung von kontrollpunkten an
hauptverkehrsstraßen das ausheben von
gräben die überwachung und kontrolle die
befestigung vorstellungen und barrikaden
tätigkeiten von den die armeeangehörigen
setzen frei bleiben sollen damit sie
sich ganz auf die kampfeinsätze
konzentrieren können nicht unnötig
erhöht werden
[Musik]
denn man darf nicht vergessen dass im
krieg die bereitschaft und versorgung
der truppe mindestens genauso viel zählt
wie ihre ausrüstung eine weitere aufgabe
der territorialen verteidigungskräfte
ist die suche und ergreifung feindlicher
soldaten im eigenen gebiet sie sind zum
beispiel in der lage sehr effizient so
genanntem open up operation
durchzuführen bei denen russische
piloten abgeschossene flugzeuge
hubschrauber aufgegriffen werden
[Musik]
das ziel ist klar keinen feind
unkontrolliert hinter den eigenen reihen
agieren zu lassen um die versorgungswege
nicht zu gefährden natürlich ist ihre
partisanen arbeit in den besetzten
gebieten noch gefährlicher dafür
brauchen sie genauso viel mut wie die im
ukrainischen soldaten an der front
dennoch gibt es immer wieder nachrichten
etwa von angriffen auf russisch
kontrollierte luftwaffenstützpunkte oder
über dieser störung eines gepanzerten
zuges oder eine eisenbahnanlage im
metropol alles wird genutzt um den
russischen angreifer zu bekämpfen und
wenn ich alles sage dann meine ich auch
wirklich alles
laut bericht töteten ukrainische
zivilisten russische soldaten mit
vergifteten kuchen man muss sich klar
machen unter welchen umständen diese
taten geschehen und in welche situation
die dinge sind die sie verüben es
handelt sich meistens um einfache leute
die dich und mich lehrer ingenieure oder
arbeiter deren leben sich ab dem 24
februar plötzlich und radikal verändert
hat und auch für die ukrainische
wirtschaft war das ganze natürlich ein
schock über nacht sind die unternehmen
wenig zerstört so doch teil einer
kriegswirtschaft geworden die tagein
tagaus auf ein einziges ziel hinarbeitet
die russen zu vertreiben und es so wie
sich ukraine in der
territorialverteidigung in dieses
vaterlandes gestellt haben gibt es
unternehmen die genau dasselbe tun
letzten monat noch haben sie
designerkleider hergestellt jetzt machen
sie kampfstiefel der erfolg der ukraine
bei der verteidigung von care
veranlasste die russen ihren schwerpunkt
auf ihre offensiven osten und süden des
landes zu verlagern diese umgruppierung
und massive von verkürzung erlaubt es
beiden seiten ihre truppen zu
konzentrieren und so sollte auch die
territorialverteidigung im osten und
süden des landes massiert werden doch
die ukrainischen militärs waren sich
nicht einig wie dies geschehen sollte
[Musik]
machtkampf der generäle
präsident salih hat sich immer dafür
eingesetzt dass die ukraine eine
professionellere armee bekommt drei
wochen vor kriegsausbruch unterzeichnete
ein dekret in dem er sich klar dazu
verpflichtete den verteidigungshaushalt
zu erhöhen und die gehälter seiner
streitkräfte anzuheben auf das ende der
wehrpflicht wurde auf das jahr 2020
festgelegt um raum zu mehr
professionalisierung zu schaffen aber
natürlich hat die russische invasion
alles verändert mittelmeier sollte in
diesem zusammenhang eine erklärung des
keys für verwirrung
sein ski feiert chef der ukrainischen
territorial verteidigungskräfte dabei
handelte es sich unter regale general
juli hallo stellen aber warum wurde er
nach 80 tagen gefeuert hatte er denn
keine gute arbeit geleistet angesichts
der effektivität der
territorialverteidigung während des
krieges wird das wohl kaum der grund
gewesen sein nun zu dieser zeit gab es
gerüchte dass halo spielen gewisse an
beziehungen pflegen könnte in die
politik zu gehen
erklärt das war unser dienst ihn
loswerden wollte bevor er an popularität
gewinnt und zu einem politischen rivalen
werden könnte es ist schwer zu glauben
dass der ukrainische präsident gerade
jetzt zeit für solcherlei intrigen hat
auch wenn er sicherlich weiß wie wichtig
seine eigene hausmacht ist aber
eigentlich hat er schon genug damit zu
tun die russen rauszuwerfen der
schlüssel zu dieser entlassung hat also
vielleicht eher mit folgenden zu tun
gerade zwei wochen vorhang schließt
entlassungen verabschiedet das
ukrainische parlament die zentrale
harada in folgenden beschluss
gerade erlaubt der
territorialverteidigung aufgabe in
kriegsgebieten auszuführen damit hat die
rhader das gesetz über die grundlagen
des nationalen widerstands vier monate
nach seinem inkrafttreten geändert
[Musik]
die wichtigste änderung ist dass die
territorialen verteidigungskräfte danach
auf dem gesamten territorium der ukraine
operieren können das heißt auch in
gebieten wo kampfeinsätze stattfinden
das ist ein wichtiges detail einsätze in
solchen gebieten werden nicht vom
kommandeur der territorialverteidigung
sondern vom oberbefehlshaber der
ukrainische streitkräfte befohlen und
wir sollten genau auf die art und weise
achten wie diese gesetzesreform
verabschiedet wurde
lasst mich das erklären laut artikel 94
der ukrainischen verfassung
klosterstraße überhaupt ein neues gesetz
innerhalb von 15 tagen unterzeichnen
oder es mit vernünftig begründeten
vorschlägen an das parlament zurückgehen
wenn der präsident das gesetz nicht
innerhalb der genannten frist
unterzeichnet und ist auch nicht um das
parallel zurückschickt tritt das gesetz
automatisch in kraft und genau das ist
im falle dieser reform passiert
[Musik]
warum aber hat sie längst nicht das in
der verfassung festgelegte verfahren
eingehalten naja vielleicht wollte er
einfach nicht die verantwortung dafür
tragen dass relativ unerfahrene
freiwillige nebenberuf soldaten an der
front kämpfen indem er das gesetz weder
unterschrieb noch blockte hatte die
verantwortung quasi auf die abgeordneten
der radar abgewälzt
[Applaus]
und sollte dieser verdacht zutreffen
dort vieles darauf hin dass der
kommandeur der territorialverteidigung
das neue gesetz nicht mittragen wollte
und zwar so wenig dass er längst die
keine andere wahl hatte als ihn zu
entlassen aber hallo stehen ist nicht
der einzige der glaubt dass die
territorialen verteidigungskräfte nicht
bereit sind an der front zu kämpfen mac
william bishop etwa ein renommierter und
militärisch erfahrener journalist
befindet sich vor ort in der ukraine und
denkt genau dasselbe die ukraine hat
alle verfügbaren einheiten in den kampf
im osten geschickt einschließlich einer
reihe von schlecht ausgebildeten
brigaden der territorialverteidigung und
freiwilligen einheiten
ich habe einige zeit mit einer der
freiwilligen einheiten verbracht die an
die front geschickt wurde und das war
eine alarmierende erfahrung ohne eigenes
verschulden wollen sie mit minimaler
ausrüstung und ohne jegliche
grundausbildung in den kampf geschickt
laut bishop werden die einheiten wenig
für den einsatz auf dem schlachtfeld
vorbereitet und sind damit oft kaum mehr
als kanonenfutter sie verfügen auch über
notwendigen kenntnisse grundlegend
andere taktik sind nun nur dürftig an
der waffe ausgebildet und auch bei der
bewegung im feld ungeübt was insgesamt
zu sehr leichten ziel für die russen
macht wohl man nicht vergessen darf dass
ähnliches auch auf viele russische
soldaten zutrifft
es ist klar dass die ukraine bereit sind
alles für ihr heimatland zu geben sogar
ihr leben aber natürlich geht es nicht
darum vergeblich also für nichts und
wieder nichts opfer zu bringen um das zu
vermeiden brauchen die ukraine vor allem
zwei dinge moderne waffen und bessere
ausbildung für ersteres zählen sie auf
die hilfe des westens aber bei der
ausbildung ist ist komplizierter auch
hier kann der westen helfen allerdings
in geringerem umfang außerdem braucht
die ausbildungszeit unter umständen sehr
viel zeit und die ist im krieg sehr
knapp trotz dieser unschönen
schwierigkeiten ist dennoch klar die
territorialverteidigung platte spielen
in der ukraine eine sehr wichtige rolle
eine so wichtige dass länder wie polen
die bereits erwähnt begonnen haben diese
struktur zu kopieren die polnische
gruppe beträgt mittlerweile 29.000 mann
und sollte es auf 53.000 ausgebaut
werden zum vergleich die regulären
streitkräfte polens umfassende rund
110.000 berufssoldaten welche nun auf
240.000 aufgestockt werden soll aber was
meint ihr soll sind die ukraine alle
verfügbaren truppen einsetzen um den
russischen angreifer zu bekämpfen kann
die nato etwas von der ukrainischen
territorial verteidigungsstrategie
lernen sollte jedes nato land über eine
solche teilstreitkraft verfügung und im
zuge dessen die der tüchtigkeit der
breiten bevölkerung allgemein erhöhen
oder ist die klassische wehrpflicht
dafür doch ein besseres modell die immer
sind auf eure beiträge und diskussionen
zu diesem thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass sich dieses video gefallen
hat war es ja gibt es mit einem leichten
frauen unvergessliches aber mit
glücklich und keines unseren videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich von rose auch
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
uns hässliches projekte weiterzuführen
denn peter link dazu findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter dem video was gut und
bis bald
[Musik]